she'll go leaving uncle vanya we shall
leave through a long long chain of days
and weary evenings we shall patiently
bear the trials which fate sends us we
shall work for others what now and in
our old age and have no rest and when
our time comes we shall die without a
murmur and there beyond the grave shall
say that we have suffering but we have
web that life has been bitter to us that
will have pity on us you and I uncle to
your uncle shall see life that is bright
beautiful and lovely we shall rejoice
and look at all these troubles of Earth
with tenderness the smile and we shall
rest I have faith uncle have fervent
passionate p we shall rest shall rest
shall hear the angels shall see all
heaven lead with radiance shall see all
of the evil who are suffering drawn and
mercy which will fill the whole world
and our life will be peaceful gentle and
sweet as a caress I happy
we have faith
for Uncle Vanya you're crying you have
had no joy in your life but wait Uncle
Vanya wait shield rest shall rest shall
rest
you